I'm here to say, as a professor of mathematics,...
...that very few people actually use calculus in a conscious,...
...,meaningful way in their day-to-day lives.
On the other hand, statistics:...
...that's a subject that you could, and should use on a daily basis, right?
It's risk.
It's reward.
It's randomness.
It's understanding data.
I think if our students, if our high school students, if all of the American citizens,...
...knew about probability and statistics,...
...we wouldn't be in the economic mess that we're in today.
Not only, thank you.
Not only that, if it's taught properly, it can be a lot of fun.
I mean, probability and statistics, it's the mathematics of games and gambling.
It's analyzing trends.
It's predicting the future.
Look, the world has changed from analog to digital.
And it's time for our mathematics curriculum to change from analog to digital.
From the more classical, continuous mathematics to the more modern, discrete mathematics.
The mathematics of uncertainty, of randomness, of data, and that being probability and statistics.
In summary, instead of our students learning about the techniques of calculus,...
...I think it would be far more significant...
...if all of them knew what "two standard deviations from the mean" means.
And I mean it.
Thank you very much.